AWAY IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
-- THEY WANT YOU TO KNOW THEY
CARE ABOUT THE CHILDREN.
THEY WILL REMIND YOU THAT
EVERYTHING THEY DO THEY DO FOR
THE KIDS.
>> IF YOU WORK HARD.
YOU CAN DO BETTER AND PASS ON
GREATER OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUR
CHILDREN.
>> THE PEOPLE MUST DETERMINE
YOUR FUTURE.
THE FUTURE OF YOUR CHILDREN.
>> IT'S ABOUT THE CHILDREN.
THE CHILDREN, THE CHILDREN, THE
CHILDREN.
>> Laura: BUT IN PRACTICE THE
CHILDREN ARE PROPS IN THEIR
QUEST FOR MORE CONTROL.
WHEN GIRLS WERE RAPED IN TWO
SCHOOLS LIBERAL SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS DID THEIR BEST TO
COVER IT UP.
WHEN THE FATHER WENT TO THE
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING THEY
ARRESTED HIM.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS IS AMERICA.
THE FATHER APPEARED ON THE
"ANGLE" TO DESCRIBE THE
EXPERIENCE.
>> MY DAUGHTER WAS SEXUAL
ASSAULTED AT THE END OF SCHOOL
IN MAY OF LAST YEAR.
I WENT TO THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEETING TO SEE WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
I TOLD THE LADY WHAT HAPPENED TO
MY DAUGHTER.
SHE LOOKED ME DEAD IN THE FACE
AND SAID THAT'S NOT WHAT
HAPPENED AND THREATENED MY
FAMILY BUSINESS.
MY LIVELY HOOD.
I AM TACKLED TO THE GROUND.
I AM JUST SHOCKED.
AND HORRIFIED.
>> Laura: AS A PARENT THIS STORY
IS UPSETTING.
THE CRIME AGAINST THIS YOUNG
WOMAN AND THE EFFORT TO VILIFY
THE FAMILY OF THE FEMALE VICTIM.
IT SEEMS TO GET WORSE EVERY DAY.
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA ROLLED
INTO RICHMOND, VIRGINIA TO STUMP
FOR TERRY MCAULIFFE AND
DISMISSED CONCERN ABOUT THE
LOUDOUN COUNTY CRIME.
>> WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO BE
WASTING ON THESE PHONEY TRUMPED
UP CULTURE WARS.
THIS FAKE OUTRAGE THAT THE RIGHT
WING PEDALS TO JUICE THEIR
RATINGS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU NEED,
VIRGINIA.
INSTEAD OF FORCING OUR
COMMUNITIES TO CUT BACK WHEN WE
ARE JUST STARTING TO RECOVER, WE
SHOULD DO MORE TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
WHO ARE EDUCATING OUR KIDS AND
KEEPING OUR NEIGHBORHOODS SAFE.
>> Laura: NEIGHBORHOOD SAFE?
THE DEMOCRAT CAN'T EVEN KEEP
THEIR SCHOOL RESTROOMS SAFE.
THEY ARE MORE WORRIED ABOUT THE
POLITICAL REPERCUSSIONS THAN THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
STUDENTS IN THIS SAGA.
THAT GOES DOUBLE FOR THE MEDIA
GOON SQUAD.
I REMEMBER WHEN THE "WASHINGTON
POST" USED TO BELIEVE IT WAS
REPREHENSIBLE TO USE THE
VICTIM'S SEXUAL HISTORY TO
IMPEACH HER CREDIBILITY.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN THIS
CASE.
THE GIRL ADMITTED SHE HAD
A RELATIONSHIP WITH HER ATTACKER
AND THEY EVEN AGREED TO MEET IN
THE BATHROOM WHEN THE ATTACK
OCCURRED.
A "WASHINGTON POST" REPORTER NOT
MENTIONING HER NAME BUT
PUBLISHED THESE DETAILS.
THE CHIEF JUDGE WHO HEARD ALL OF
THE EVIDENCE IN THIS CASE
DECIDED THAT THE ACCUSED MALE
TEENAGER WHO WORE A SKIRT DID
COMMIT THE SEXUAL ASSAULT BUT
THE REPORTER WAS NOT HAPPY WITH
THAT.
MY QUESTION IS:
WHERE ARE ALL OF THE WOMEN WHO
STOOD UP FOR VICTIMS IN THE
PAST!
LET'S REMEMBER THEIR WORDS.
>> HOW MANY WOMEN AND MEN ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WHO ARE HARASSED AND
HAVE NO VOICE?
>> THAT'S WHY PEOPLE DON'T TELL
THEIR STORIES INTO WE HAVE TO
CREATE A SAFE SPACE FOR WOMEN TO
COME FORWARD.
>> Laura: THE "WASHINGTON POST"
BELIEVED THAT NO MEANS NO.
NOW, WHO WANTS WOMEN TO SHUT UP
AND GO AWAY?
THE DEMOCRATS WHO CLAIMED TO BE
THE "ME TOO" DEFENDERS.
EVEN KIDS ARE REALIZING THEIR
SCHOOLS ARE A MESS.
SCHOOLS IN HIGH SCHOOLS
PARTICIPATED IN WALK OUTS TODAY
TO PROTEST FOR SAFER SCHOOLS
AFTER THE LOUDOUN COUNTY SCHOOL
BOARD DENIED THESE ATTACKS
OCCURRED.
PARENTS ARE FED UP.
THE LATEST OUTRAGE INVOLVES
LOUDOUN COUNTY REQUIREMENTS THAT
PARENTS MUST SIGN
A NONDISCLOSURE TO VIEW ITS RACE
AND EQUITY CURRICULUM.
AS PART OF THE SCHOOL'S EQUITY
AGENDA THE DISTRICT SPENT $7,700
TO BECOME A LICENSED USE OF THE
SECOND STEP PROGRAM.
PARENTS MUST SIGN THE DOCUMENT
TO VIEW THE SECOND STEP
CURRICULUM.
ALL BOARD MEMBERS WHO WERE
ATTACKING PARENTAL RIGHTS,
MAKING THEM SIGN AN AGREEMENT
THEY WON'T TALK ABOUT IT.
THEY HAVE TO BE THROWN OUT ON
THEIR YOU KNOW WHAT IN THE NEXT
GO AROUND.
THE CAMPAIGN AGAINST PARENTAL
INVOLVEMENT IN SCHOOLS IS LED BY
LEFT WING ACTIVISTS LIKE JACK
SNYDER AND JENNIFER BERKSHIRE.
WRITING IN THE "WASHINGTON POST"
PARENTS CLAIM THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO SHAPE THEIR KIDS SCHOOL
CURRICULUM.
THAT WOULD RISK INHIBITING THE
ABILITY OF YOUNG PEOPLE TO THINK
INDEPENDENTLY.
RANDY THE HEAD OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS LOVES
THIS.
TWEETING, GREAT PIECE ON PARENTS
RIGHTS IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THAT'S FUNNY.
SHE MEANS THE RIGHT TO STEP
ASIDE AND LEAD THE EXPERTS
CONTROL IT ALL.
WHO ON EARTH WOULD TOLERATE THIS
DISRESPECT?
THIS WILL ONLY MAKE MATTERS
WORSE WHERE PARENTS STARTED
THEIR OWN WALK OUT.
LOUDOUN COUNTRY IS GROWING BUT
ITS SCHOOL ENROLLMENT IS
DROPPIN
DROPPING.
THE SCHOOLS ARE LOSING STATE
FUNDING.
GOOD.
AND THE FAIRFAX COUNTY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ARE ALSO SEEING TROUBLE.
ALL OF LAST YEAR WE WARNED THEM
THAT IF THEY KEPT THEIR SCHOOLS
CLOSED FOR IN PERSON LEARNING
AND DUMBING DOWN THEIR
CURRICULUM PARENTS WOULD PULL
THEIR KIDS OUT.
THAT'S HAPPENED.
THE DISTRICT IS DOWN 10,000
STUDENTS FROM THE PRE-PANDEMIC
LEVEL.
THEY MOVED THEIR CHILDREN TO
PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
OTHERS OPTED FOR HOME SCHOOLING.
OTHERS WENT TO AREAS WHERE
SCHOOLS WERE OPERATING IN
PERSON.
SCHOOL LEADERS ACKNOWLEDGE WHEN
IT COMES TO STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS
PRE-PANDEMIC THEY HAVE NO IDEA
WHERE THEY HAVE GONE.
THESE PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE KIDS HAVE GONE ARE IN
CHARGE OF YOUR KIDS EDUCATION?
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY TERRIFYING.
DON'T WORRY.
THEIR PRIORITIES INCLUDE PAIRING
BACK ON AP-COURSES AND MANDATING
THAT ATHLETES GET THE
VACCINATIONS.
PARENTS ARE NOT JUST WALKING OUT
ON THESE RADICAL SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS.
THEY WANT TO THROW THEM ALL OUT.
>> OUR KIDS ARE TOO IMPORTANT.
WE CAN'T ASSUME EVERYBODY ELSE
WILL TAKE CARE OF THIS.
WE HAVE PHENOMENAL TEACHERS BUT
IT'S THE LEADERSHIP.
>> I NOT HAVE HEARD MCAULIFFE
SAY I WILL VISITING WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE SCHOOLS.
I HEARD YOUNGKIN SAY THAT.
GIVE HIM A SHOT.
>> HOW ABOUT THE FORMER GOVERNOR
SAYING PARENTS SHOULD NOT BE
INVOLVED.
>> MY HEAD WAS ABOUT TO EXPLODE.
>> Laura: AND GLENN YOUNGKIN
DROPPED AN AD THAT MCAULIFFE HAS
HAD A LONG HISTORY OF VETO BILLS
FOR EDUCATION.
>> IT WAS BIPARTISAN.
IT GAVE PARENTS A SAY.
THE OPTION TO CHOOSE AN
ALTERNATIVE FOR MY CHILDREN.
BUT THEN GOVERNOR TERRY
MCAULIFFE VETOED IT TWICE.
HE DOESN'T THINK PARENTS SHOULD
HAVE A SAY.
HE SAID THAT.
HE SHUT US OUT.
>> Laura: A DEVASTATING AD.
THESE ARE NOT PHONEY CULTURE
WARS.
THIS IS ABOUT WHO HAS THE FINAL
SAY ABOUT THE PRESENT AND FUTURE
OF OUR KIDS EDUCATION.
THIS IS ABOUT WHOM YOU TRUST TO
KEEP YOUR CHILDREN SAFE WITH
A SCHOOL HAS WOKE TEACHERS OR
ADMINISTRATORS CAN'T BE TRUSTED.
THEY HAVE OTHER PRIORITIES.
THE WALK OUTS TODAY IN VIRGINIA
ARE ONLY THE BEGINNING.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS ABOUT TO
EXPERIENCE WHAT A